hello hello
happy july
happy july to you i want to thank you
i'm happy to be here with you i'm happy
to be
just you know sitting here anecdoting
with you
and and just
being in years
just get you know
creeping my way into your brain i'm
happy
i'm happy that you're here happy july to
you um
i just got out of ice plunge i've been
doing a lot of uh
ice bathing
you know i got an ice bath and this
company called blue cube they make them
and
i get in there
and i need it right now you know i feel
real fortunate to have it because i need
it
because something is happening right now
and i'm talking about the heat baby
the heat
it i mean it
is if
you go outside you say dang
it's just like a bunch of damn lights
just [ __ ] you
it's hot
this damn hot you see people you know
people you know you see a kid running
through the playground if his hair gets
just burnt off his head damn
damn bald children running around
i was just a bunch of hot-headed little
kid just
just steam coming off their head
tickling each other
and doing swing setting
you see it
you see somebody lose a damn a strong
piece of sun hit em and they lose
eyebrow
somebody mr ron is showing up to work
half a mustache
they got some strong rays out there
and i'm not talking about sugar ray
leonard or sugar ray the band who was
all right they were all right
i'm talking about
rey baby
the lord's damn long arm son
mother nature got that hot nut up there
just busting
damn i mean it's hot
i got in my truck yesterday i couldn't
even touch the but i couldn't touch
anything i got out
i said [ __ ] i'm just going to go i'll do
a damn uh
i'll just call them
i'll i ca i can't do i can't touch the
wheel can't deceit
and god forbid you still have those
metal plug-ins for your um
uh seat thing
that you're you're you you you're out of
work now you can't get to work
it is i mean it is hot
there's heat everywhere
there's just i mean
the sun is just [ __ ] looking for
people
irish people are dying they're dying
name 40 irish people right now
i bet you can't
and that's the yes you win baby
that's that of a [ __ ] baby that big dog
in the sky
that big orange ginger mf or sun you
know what i'm talking about
sun
sunshine
that [ __ ] is beating people
that [ __ ] is beating people
this damn it's hot
you know you see a uh
a cat run through a puddle and burn his
damn burn her hair off his legs
you see it you know
you see a bird take two sips out of a
bird bath and [ __ ] just fall over
just damn death soup he ate
we can't handle it
and i you know what i just i i don't
know how to stop it
you know you can do prayer you can do
umbrellas
but name you know
you almost got to write a damn hem on
the outside of an umbrella to even get a
little
respite from the heat
the shit's cooking you son
[ __ ]
i walk to i feel like a damn tv dinner
halfway through the yard i'm going to
the mailbox
i'm like [ __ ]
i feel like a damn salisbury steak damn
i can't handle it
and then i start hearing oh you a little
[ __ ] some of the sun will say that what
you this [ __ ] is this this heat is for
real this shit's from [ __ ] detroit
son
it's a different time flowers have given
up i haven't seen a flower since may
them [ __ ] is gone
they're potpourri now you see you know
you had a rose bush that [ __ ]
potpourri now it's all it's steamed out
your garden it's steamed vegetables you
didn't even want them steamed them
[ __ ] is steamed son you better eat
now
it's a wrap
and i don't know people say that it's uh
you know global warming people say that
it's um
the end of times and
you know it's tough to know exactly what
mother nature has planned
because we started with the ice age
that's when mother nature they had so
much meat running around in the world
mother nature said damn imma save some
hit it with that ice baby that big
freezer box damn bam
i mean hell you go up with a good pick
axe
and a george foreman grill and a knife
and fork up through the antarctica
you're going to be living thick baby
you're going to be eating well
because that's that that's a damn ice
box up there
but it's hot and it's warm in the world
and i hope you're keeping cool finding a
way
somebody yesterday mentioned the gas
prices too i said gas it's [ __ ] it's
hot as [ __ ]
the last thing anybody needs is gas i
don't care how i don't care if that [ __ ]
is 40 cents a gallon [ __ ] i don't want
no gasoline
do you try to fill your car up you
[ __ ] damn
that's a carbocus son you [ __ ] gonna
get roasted you idiot
i just call in i do work over the phone
that's it
people wanting gasoline but you out of
your mind this ain't no time for that
we don't need that
we don't need that man
it's a it's a wild time man it's a wild
time going on out in the world i even
saw in the news this is in the news
if you believe in news and that's okay
if you do not
that bees
bees bumblebees baby gods little hit men
are ejaculating themselves to death
in heat waves
bees across europe
may die from the severe heat plaguing
the continent this week
ejaculating explosively as they do
a doctor said we don't know exactly why
but drones ejaculate when they get too
stressed
ejaculation kills them because it
basically eviscerates their abdomen they
bust big son
a bee that thang black and yellow black
and yellow thanks
that's that little winged skeet demon
that thing a beast that thing
this happens during natural mating too
drone honeybees always die after mating
that that's a tough time right there
when bees
are ejaculating
and dying because of the heat
too much heating and dam you know
and the beat they bust out
and just eviscerate into the universe
they can't handle it
when animals nuts is busting because of
the heat
when the heat just got these little
insects just
just sun coming
that's something baby that's that that's
the dark art baby that's not good
that's when the devil's at the door
knock knock baby who's there
bees baby bees who
bees nuts son
bees are [ __ ] blowing up
that's how hot it is the animals are
[ __ ] just bam i'm out
you got to take care of yourself
and you got to take care of your cousin
put a cold rag on your cousin's neck
put an ice cube in the baby's ass
son we got to take care of each other
it's a new time out there
and the sun is [ __ ] people
people getting damn just heat aids on
their face you see somebody got heat
aids
on their neck
because the sun just just done
done just damn got them
just just you know
bees are flying by and just damn just
skeeting out blowing up
it's time to take care of ourselves and
it's time to take care of each other
i believe we can do it
now let's get into the episode baby
welcome to this past weekend
[Music]
come on
[Music]
oh
well i just broke up with my baby
[Music]
things keep on coming
and i ain't gonna win
[Music]
yeah
i like that one
and i like the young man that makes that
music there
and that is eddie 9 volt
[Music]
the come up
and i like them i like that music
i like the sounds that come out of them
i like the
it makes me feel excited
it makes me feel hopeful it makes me
feel like i'm back
i'm feeling good i just got out that
cold plunge i've been doing a lot of
things like that recently
i got a trainer
that i've been using i feel fortunate
enough to be able to afford that and i
got a trainer that i've been using
and um
and uh man it's been
it has been helping me
to a level i can't even explain
um i went six days this week
um
and i feel i mean i just feel
you know i feel more outside of myself
i don't feel as inside inside of myself
you know and i don't feel as in my head
because now i'm using my body i've got a
lot of my blood
and a lot of my energy which was just
whirling around in my head
which is not a safe place to be
now it's kind of dispersed out
and i feel the more even
you know i think a long time ago as as
human beings we had we had to use our
senses and we had to use them in the
world
you know you had to be like oh there's
uh you know if you walked out there into
the woods there's a lion possibly
and you might hear a damn little warbler
in the distance and he might be giving
you a clue oh there's a lion you know
and you'd have to be careful because
maybe there would be a
uh poison ivy
or poison sumac
or some you know something
but you have to be aware of your
surroundings
yeah you know all your feelings were
outside of you
you had to look at the sky what is the
weather what does the air feel like
what's going on here
so all of our feelings used to be
outside of us you had to be aware you
had to survive
and then humanity we got our society
especially in america we got into
more like
everybody's
everybody's comfortable enough
we all have a bed we all have a roof
you know it's it's safe enough we don't
you know we don't all of our senses we
haven't used them like that in a long
time
so now my sense is i feel like a lot of
times they go they've started to go
inward
because there's nothing that alertness
that
that uh
it's not it's not necessary in the
outside so now they've all gone inward
but they're still hunting the lion
they're still looking for something
that's uncomfortable or dangerous or
alarming
and so that's where i feel like a lot of
our mental health is now
it's like
the senses that we used to use in
to survive
we don't need them outside of us anymore
so now those sensors they're lurking
around inside of me looking for looking
for lions
but there is no lions in me
unless i'm some kind of damn centaur or
something there is no lions in me or
unless i've eaten a couple cuts of lion
so it just it finds this you know
anything that's a little spooky it finds
like things from my past or
fears
um
it finds uh
trouble it finds some trouble but it
makes it feel like it's a lion you know
i don't know if that makes any sense but
to me part of it does it's like
all those senses we used to use and need
to survive
because we were wandering around
in a world
in the open
having to go into caves and see if it
was safe to sleep
you know
[Music]
having to you know
know when the sun's coming up so we
could navigate the next day
we had to just be uh our a lot of our
alertness was outside of our body
because it needed to be
but i've been feeling uh i've been
feeling a little better
you know
and i've just been
yeah just trying to focus on taking care
of myself uh
yeah just um you know going to more
meetings spending time with friends
doing some things that i don't want to
do
some time to get out of my comfort zone
[Music]
even the ice plunge the ice bath that's
i don't want to get in that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
that thing it's
it's uncomfortable
but i need you know i
i don't know i'm finding
i don't know i'm just
it's working
so i'm just sticking with what's working
right now for me um
what else is happening what else has
been going on i went to
uh jimmy john had his summer camp
the sandwich man the sandwich mogul
you know he's a friend of mine and he's
been uh he's been a guest here on this
past weekend
and he had his summer camp so i went out
there and got to do some fishing
[Music]
uh with emeril emerald was out there the
chef the famous chef
and um
you know he likes to fish and
and i like to fish so we got out there a
couple louisiana guys and that was
beautiful
just to get to be on a you know fishing
boat and ask him about desserts
that's what i did mostly
you know i just i mean i just kept
whispering little desserts by them tier
me sue
you know
um
and i would just say stuff you know just
like uh potatoes all grug you know i'll
just kind of mumble little recipes under
my breath and stuff and see if and you'd
see him sometimes
you know you see him he could pick up or
you know
he could he could
if you throw out a low decibel recipe
around that man he'll hear it that's
just where he's at uh but that was
really beautiful man that was exciting
just fun
caught some um
bass and i think caught me a little
amberjack
and uh
what else hmm
i'm trying to think of what else has
been going on oh
[Music]
not too much
you know i'm taking a break little break
off of dayton so i haven't been doing
any dating
trying not to touch my junk bro trying
to stay off that freaking skeet handle
um
[Music]
yeah
that's really about it i don't know if
anything else oh i went to dinner over
at kid rock's house
uh that was amazing
we had a nice time over there and he's
got a spinning table in his living in
his
dining room and it's like a spins around
so if you you know
you can get you know you get up to go
pee and you come back and you damn
you don't know where you are you know
it's almost like double dutch you're
just waiting for the chance to get back
into your seat to get back to your damn
appetizer that [ __ ] is eight nine feet
away now
you know you half a caesar salad that
[ __ ] is damn 40 degrees away now
because the whole table at all the whole
thing spins so you can all you can just
continually pass by this beautiful uh
outlook
over the mountains and stuff and it's
it's nice man it was really really it
was
it's just beautiful when they had scenic
um
the food was nice and
um
yeah it was just good man you know it
was interesting i never spent on
something like that
where the table
you know it kind of it's f you know it's
trying to get you dizzy almost like it's
trying to [ __ ] you
you know if you know if it's
you know i don't know if it's trying to
do that but if you got dizzy enough and
laid there i bet it would
i bet it would [ __ ] touch your ass a
little
i bet
i don't know
i wasn't over there that long
um
but yeah i just had a nice time then i
and i gone up to jimmy john's summer
camp up in wisconsin and his family's
all there and that was beautiful
um
caleb presley was up there he's been a
guest here
so it was nice to get to see him and
spend some time
um
and yeah just fished and ate
and had some nice dreams at night and
just staying alive that's it
just staying alive at the moment
oh
i'm trying to think of something else i
wanted to share
[Music]
um oh i got my hair i did when they had
a hair surgery a few weeks ago
so
i got a few more taken out the back and
plugged into the front somewhere
so uh because i was shedding i was
shedding a little i had some hair loss
so that's nice you know how i had to
re-enlist them [ __ ] in the front
you know we had to support our troops
baby
so i'm glad to have a little bit extra
you know we'll see
hopefully they put in something damn
[ __ ] beautiful up there hopefully i
get a damn cornrow up there or something
something beautiful to pop out
you know i take care of my
mind and my brain by going to therapy
and by being uh active
those are ways that i do and my
therapist helps you know i see a woman
right now that's a therapist and a man
actually i got two therapists right now
and um
you have to you gotta take care of that
brain you gotta let it get things in and
get things out with the help of someone
else
it's like your car you know you gotta
clean under the seats you know you got
to get that gunk out throw up that throw
out that old banana
and there are plenty ways to support a
healthy brain
and one of those is better help online
therapy
better betterhelp has helped me
uh it's a way to
have contact with a counselor
licensed professional therapist
you can switch between different ones to
get one that you like you can do
whatever face time you can do it on your
phone
um if you feel uncomfortable about going
into a building
or going into a place if you live in a
small area and you think there might be
judgment
it's online therapy that's what it is
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist
in under 48 hours if you need help
please
do it do it for yourself
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p-com
theo
you know it's uh it's tough in life to
to find time that becomes really the
biggest uh currency
it's time it's tough to it's tough to
create more of it
but there is a way
if you run a business to do that
it's by making your shipping more
effective that's right
ship station automates time
intensive shipping processes so you can
get back to focusing on bigger things
like developing new products honing your
marketing strategy or interacting with
customers no wonder shipstation is
already trusted by over a hundred
thousand sellers
it works with all your storefronts
amazon ebay etsy and more
also you can easily compare carriers
rates and delivery time so it's easy to
choose the best option for every
shipping scenario
sign up today using promo code theo
for a free 60-day trial today at
shipstation.com
and start saving time with every
shipment that's two whole months of
shipping made quick and painless and
it's free to try just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in t-h-e-o
ship station make ship
happen
and i want to thank uh
who you know the last touring we did a
tour through florida
and
some fella made me a real nice amulet
from a wrist it's a real nice little
amulet
and then someone a
lady
um
and knitted me
uh
a rat king
and a a a doll of
crush-headed doll of me
and a
rat
and um if you're watching on youtube
we'll have the picture in here right now
so you can see it but man
it just
you know i just felt so lucky i just
just the just the support
i just appreciate it and we put on some
fire shows too fire
so
so that's kind of what's been going on
with me you know um we took a week off
of the show a few weeks ago gonna take
another one off um uh in the future
so just getting uh
you know just feeling taking it easy
taking care of myself
doing the fitness doing the cold
plunging
um
on my medicine you know i'm saying i'm
milligrammed up
uh i'm back on medication so that's
uh i think it's okay
you know i'm not trying to be too crazy
about it right now i went down that
ayahuasca road
and got out there and really was just
you know
just surfing on my own dick out there
you know and sometimes
uh
it was definitely helpful and amazing um
but i'm
i feel like i'm happy
with what's going on right now so
um i'm on i think i'm on lexapro i don't
know or the cheap one
you know that's where i'm at i take that
cheap [ __ ] son
the name you can't even pronounce you're
like oh [ __ ] it i'll take it i'll take
that [ __ ] boy
so uh that's what's kind of new in my
life
not doing no love right now not doing no
sex
um
and yeah just trying not to uh
touch my wiener or nothing and just
hoping i bust at night that's what i'd
like like one of them bees baby just
buzz baby you know
just hoping i just lay there and just
you know just hoping god touches me in
my sleep
praise god baby
uh we got some beautiful calls and
videos and everything that came in from
you guys um i want to get into some of
that because i haven't heard from you in
a while i know we had a few guest
episodes in a row
but i was so excited to talk to mike
perry and uh i was excited that riff
raff came through
and so we had to get those in to you and
i'm glad that we did
as always the hotline is 985
985-664-9503
uh some great calls that came in from
you
so i want to hear some of those now
hi there this is alyssa in new orleans i
first want to say thank you
alyssa
thank you for the call in new orleans
baby gnarling baby nylons
and um
and yeah i love new orleans you know
i love spending time there as a child
and
my dad got stabbed over there brought by
a brother one time with a screwdriver
but
um
but we had you know
we had a lot of nice times also and also
um
my um
[Music]
my dad had a buddy
and he had uh
one of his limbs he had a limited limb
one of his limb wasn't very long his leg
one of his legs just didn't want to
you know was just didn't want to [ __ ]
do it all
and it was shorter than his other leg
and he used to stand on this piece of
concrete all the time he wouldn't leave
it
because he looked even on it
and he looked real even on and he'd stay
over there and stand on that thing
you know
and uh that was beautiful pretty
beautiful to see that see a man just be
in one place all the time just evened
out because he had that chunk of
concrete under
one of his limbs over there beautiful
[ __ ] onward sorry i'm i'm chatting what
else you got there alyssa thank you so
much for all the work you do and i
really appreciate how transparent you
are and how artistic you are
oh that's sweet of you uh miss i
appreciate it onward
so really quick question i just want to
get your opinion about uh tall
women that's what i'm saying out the
gate
yum
onward i myself am 5 10
and my partner is 5 10 5 11. it doesn't
bother me i mean
i used to have like an issue growing up
just like with my own
posture and things like that i mean i'm
definitely more confident now i keep
suga you know i take care of my body i
stand tall what have you but i don't
know i just want to get your opinion
like
look i'll tell you right now i like a
tall woman
you know i like a you know
a little portable woman too but a tall
woman
well i guess it's i guess it's
it's some men are feel afraid of it
you know some men i think they want it
they consider and be some men will marry
tall women because they also want to
marry a man they consider him gay
and
okay and if you're if i'm but but
they're afraid to either be gay or they
are not gay
and so they just get a tall woman that's
hey you know
they say you know maybe i would love to
have a man but i'm not doing it
so i'm just going to get a tall woman
you know and cut her hair short and put
her in jerseys and stuff you'll see a
lot of times
you'll have a dude out there that seems
kind of like you know
like he could you know be for men
and he'll have his wife there and have
her in a damn dennis rodman jersey and
with a damn fade on the side and you're
like damn
he really carved her up you know he
really carved her up
so uh
what are you asking about oh i like a
tall i like a tall bird
you know i like that lady hell yeah that
long
that long lady
i like that run and jump up into that
bitch's arms you know what i'm saying
i like a tall i like it nine feet tall
get that bit way up there i can't even
see her
you know i'm just
just just puss level weather you know
what i'm saying i'm just that's right
you know that'd be fine
i like a long you know hang a damn bird
feeder off her ear
i like getting two earrings damn bird
feeders
that [ __ ] up there babysitting warblers
and i'm down here hanging out by them
pockets baby you know what i'm talking
about puss
so i think that yeah i like a long woman
too
because sometimes uh also if you're if
you go somewhere and you all meet need
to meet up in a group like at a concert
or something y'all can meet up
meet up at the tall lady
let's meet up at belinda
at 7 pm meet up at tiffany
i like that
so yeah i like a long woman i like a
long leg sometime
you know they had a lady had one leg
that came out to one of the shows i
think in texas
and she brought that [ __ ] out and let
me hold it
[ __ ] awesome man almost damn teared
up
you know every time i get a hold of a
damn good orthotic i [ __ ]
i can feel the wells start filling up
inside of me god
because we had a place by us
probably on the other side of these
little woods they had a little place
they made orthotics over there
extra limbs
and sometimes they wouldn't
you know they didn't had some faulty
ones or
people had used them they had some
refurbished and they couldn't get the
knee right or whatever
or the [ __ ] ankle only you know they
had one of them had a outward ankle or
something on it and they just tossed
them [ __ ]
so as children we go get up we go p you
know scavenge over there sometime
roll out of there with a couple of damn
you know crews out of there with an arm
crews out of there with a couple feet
you know half a little sack of phalanges
bro we
you know just fun [ __ ] halloween you
know especially around halloween we try
to get over there see if we get anything
and sometimes you get you a good rubber
leg
that somebody had had
i remember one fella just kept it r i
guess he'd taken a pen and just kept
writing his name into this rubber kind
of
rubber leg you notice ernie ernie ernie
he written
the dude i guess unless he was writing
somebody else's name
but he you know pretty cool
anyway
but yeah i like a tall women you guys
are doing good and i like seeing y'all
out in the world
you know and we need all types of women
so i'm glad you're out there alyssa
thank you for the call
we got another question came in right
here this is uh
a caller
uh onward
stop brother man
this is john calling from illinois
what's up john
up there in illinois
and i like illinois you know used to pee
in a guy's car up there
and he was nice about it and i'm
grateful for that man i love that place
and my mother grew up out there in
wyoming illinois
and she used to really
you know she used to enjoy her childhood
up there and
that state has a big place in my heart
onward
i had a question for you dude i'm for
one i'm taking a dookie right now i
apologize for that
dang bubba
but at least your uh efficiency
you know you're doing efficiency brother
and i don't like it
but i respect it
but uh so my dad had just recently
passed
and he was an amputee and had a fake leg
bruh
i
want to save that leg
take it to ball games and everything
else and chug beers out of it
you think that's a good idea or what
look i appreciate you calling man and um
this is crazy we're just talking about
this
and so
you know i have a little bit of
experience with extra limb
and i'm going to say this man first of
all
yeah you got to do something with it
you know put it to use man that thing
that damn that tibia or whatever that
[ __ ] got magic in it
you know it's the last piece of your
father you have
you know maybe hanging in the garage and
you know like some people hang a tennis
ball so they know when to stop the car
hang that [ __ ] right there
every time you you know
the windshield of your dodge neon or
whatever hits that thing you're gonna
remember pops
and you're gonna stop the car stop for
pops it could be a little moniker
you know every time stop for pops bam
hit that leg
that's beautiful bro
or put that [ __ ] in it get some damn
light some candles around that [ __ ] and
ask it questions
that [ __ ] got powers in it bruh you
out here chugging beers out of it
like a [ __ ] homeless kid dude are you
out of your mind
that's a piece of your damn father
and you're doing business calls and [ __ ]
come on bro
i mean is it you know
your dad lost his [ __ ] leg
so you could sit around and do [ __ ]
calls
but i don't think so baby
i don't think so
you know what that makes me want to do
that makes me want to vape on this
[ __ ] plant
that's what you get boy
take care it's the last piece of your
father you know how much i'd i'd love to
have a piece of my dad
i'd love to have a damn earlobe of my
father's or something
you know when you out here with a whole
damn limb bruh
then you [ __ ] sipping damn uh
blue moons out that [ __ ] or whatever
get your life together bro
get off the [ __ ] and get out in the
yard and [ __ ] hit dingers with that
[ __ ]
you know
drive down the street at night and hit
people's mailboxes
give your dad a [ __ ] life bro
a fake leg never dies man
that and a fake leg never dies bro
that's is it's halfway between ghosts
and human man and you got that [ __ ]
you know sneak that [ __ ] into the
olympics dude
get a job running the torch and then
surprise him
like that [ __ ] at the top
and run that you know run it to wherever
damn iowa you know cedar rapids run that
[ __ ] over there
throw you know have let the kids have a
sleepover and just hum that [ __ ] into
the tent in the middle of the night
[ __ ] em up bruh
but do something man do something
special
but live a little man that's what i tell
you to be real honest with you i'm sorry
for getting angry at you
but somebody has to tell you something
man
maybe that's why he left that bro
she could get a kick in the ass and get
some motivation going
gang baby
let's get into another call what else we
got here
hey this is hunter from kentucky
hunter
from kentucky
that checks out onward i called earlier
and left the message i got kind of
nervous so i got to kind of cut it short
well i appreciate you calling back man
yeah i know it's kind of it can be kind
of hard to just leave a message if it's
something that means something to you or
even if it does and i know it's a lot
for you guys to just put your voice in
there and so i appreciate it and it's
okay if you have to call back
uh thank you onward um i just got a
question um
i struggle with a lot of anger and stuff
like that
and uh
i kind of take it out on my wife and so
sometimes
i mean i'm young and so but that's only
20 years old
and um
one of you got me advice
um about uh controlling anger
or um
maybe
like
controlling myself a little bit more to
make my days go better and so my dad get
mad and when i gotta go to work so today
man i love you love the podcast
it's awesome man
gang baby thank you for the call bub uh
i'm sorry that you're dealing with this
and i i appreciate you calling about it
um
you know it's nice that you care enough
you know you care enough about your wife
you're able to get a little
a little
uh oversight of yourself you know you're
able to see okay
this anger isn't helping me um
[Music]
you know i was dealing with a lot of
anger a few years ago uh
even eight months ago
um
i just wanted everything to be a certain
way
you know and i couldn't control
everything
and um
[Music]
and so that left me angry i was like
this needs to be like this i couldn't
control everything
and that left me real real angry
i was having a tough time um
and some things that i've done for me is
i've started a lo a little bit of
meditation
you know just 10 minutes put my timer on
you can look up some youtube videos how
to meditate and uh
that helps give me a little more space
before i'm gonna get angry it gives me a
little more space
between me and the world
because the world is gonna make me angry
and if i'm right on if i'm right on top
of the world
then
whenever something happens i'm right
there
but meditation starts to give you a
little bit of space between the world
and you it just gives you a little bit
of space
um
i find that that helps i find that
asking god to
to help you know god i'm i find myself
being really angry
you know and and it affects me and it it
affects
my loved ones um
and i don't like
it you know and god can you help me uh
to figure out what's going on
um
and if you believe in god or not it can
be the universe it can be a higher power
um
but putting it out there like that it
kind of makes you feel not so
alone about it and you'll start to get
some in some feedback from the world
from god
from whatever you believe you'll start
to get some feedback from it
um
yeah i'm trying to think of what what
was really
you know and this would be a good one if
people have some suggestions for hunter
about how to handle this anger
and i guess i can't really tell if it's
about your wife or you're just saying
that it comes out towards her
but one thing i've also noticed for
myself is even going back to this doing
fitness and stuff that's been helping me
a lot
you know it's been helping me get out of
myself just it just gets a lot of energy
out of me
um
[Music]
and it makes me feel more in control
a lot of times i feel anger when i'm not
in i i'm not in control in in some way
and so anger just comes out
[Music]
um let me try and think about it for
just a second
you know i didn't like being angry man
i'd find myself i could i was literally
watching myself behave ways that i
didn't want to be
and a lot of it was because
for me it was control i wanted things to
be a certain way they weren't that way
certain things
and i couldn't control it all
um
[Music]
and so for me i started to have to get a
higher power i had to get a higher power
that helps me
it's not it's out of my control
oh and thank god it is because i can't
control everything
and i was trying to
and now it's like hey god that's your
job you do it
you're doing it anyway i'm just
pretending i am and it's causing me a
lot of frustration
uh sir those are some things that help
me
but i'd love some suggestions actually
for hunter and we can put those at the
end of
an upcoming solo episode
uh just hit the hotline 985-664-9503
[Music]
but thank you man i'm going to play that
part again where you talked about
uh
what was going on so people can uh know
how to respond i struggle with a lot of
anger and stuff like that
and uh
i kind of take it out on my wife and so
sometimes
i'm young and so but that's only 20
years old
and um
one of you got me advice
um
about uh controlling anger
controlling myself a little bit more to
make my days go better and so my dad get
mad and when i gotta go to work somebody
hate me
it bothers me i don't know why
gang baby um oh another thing that i do
i started doing is when i get up in the
morning
uh
you know and i'm i'm kind of lucky i
think cause i have some time right now
to do this so but i'll do a small prayer
i'll do a meditation um and then one of
the first things i do is i'll check in
with other people i start checking in
with other people um
you know i'll call different friends
i'll just check in what's going on with
you what's going on with you uh so then
i'm not thinking about myself
i'm thinking about them
and um and that takes some pressure off
of me i notice
um
[Music]
there's also you know you could do a
12-step program there's like
you may have anger and resentments
uh in your life that you don't really
know about
you know there's all types of um
there's al-anon there's uh coda
there's um
uh acoa adult children of alcoholics
i'm not saying that you
any of that is part of your life i'm
just trying to think of you could even
just go do one of those programs and it
would help you solve some of these
things
you know if you did a 12-step program
there may even be one for anger
specifically
and you can go to zoom and you listen to
other people talk and one of them is
going to say something that's really
going to
help you
but you know having gratitude writing
gratitude lists
you know it's hard to be angry and
grateful at the same time
um
oh and i just i got this grateful shirt
on today this is from uh our boy dustin
poirier from his shirt
you can he has these shirts and um
anyway man i'm sorry you're dealing with
that but i'm glad you're at a young age
bro if you're looking at yourself to see
what's going on with you and it's
awesome that you care about your wife
and uh you know you want to figure some
of this out and you recognize that it's
hurting you that it's hurting your world
you know that's powerful man
um
so right there that's really you know
you should feel good about yourself for
that
i think that's really special
uh you know i was angry for a long time
i had a lot of anger and resentment um
towards my past and family and stuff
like that and uh
and i'm still working through that stuff
and
i'm hopeful about it so
but we'll try to get some suggestions
from people and throw those on at the
end of the next episode
uh but keep your head up baby gang
man i wore mine today
i warmed today to stop that dirty sun
from getting at my face balls my eyes
ladies and gentlemen gooder
has some amazing
sunglasses at just 25
a pair they're clean durable 100
polarized they look
nice they look fancier than the price
they have uh names like a ginger's soul
and going to valhalla
[Music]
head to g-o-o-d-r.com
t-h-e-o
use the code theo for percent off that's
g o o d r dot com
slash t-h-e-o and use code theo for
fifteen percent off protect your eyes
and see the future
you know i wear i wear my gooders
because they're stylish
they look kind of um
they make me feel hip
but also i lose sunglasses all the time
and if i lose them at this price point
i'm going to be upset
but it's not going to hit me that hard
as if you lose one of them fancy fancy
pairs
they're fun they're fashionable they're
functional 30-day free returns
gooder is giving fifteen percent off
your entire order
g-o-o-d-r dot com slash theo when you
use code theo at checkout you get 15 off
i know a lot of you uh do stuff on the
web
and you wonder if people can see it will
they be able to track this how safe is
this
people were like you should use
incognito mode well that's fine but
incognito mode does not hide your
activity
it doesn't what matter what mode you use
or how many times you clear your
browsing history your internet service
provider can still see every single
website you've ever visited
even when you're at home
that's why i never go online without
using express vpn
it's an app that reroutes your internet
connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the sites you visit you want
protection this is it
express vpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you to not
be using it
that's right you're not safe
unless you're using expressvpn protect
your online activity today with the vpn
rated number one
by business insider visit my exclusive
link
expressvpn.com
theo
and you can get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn.com
t-h-e-o-e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash theo
to learn more
all right let's see uh we got a call
that came in right here
um
this is uh an update from someone oh hey
theo this is jordan uh
calling in from mandeville louisiana
what's up jordan over there in
mandeville baby
and my god i spent a lot of good time
over there
and i remember the night that the taco
bell opened up and
people were damned fired up people were
[ __ ] beating their stepchildren and
drinking dr pepper and just [ __ ] you
know and just god people were excited
and
um
me and my buddies
got all high you know we was high on
something
you know probably whippets and uh weed
maybe the w's we were
making it through the alphabet that year
and we got pretty far
and uh
we got all baked out and was headed to
the taco bell like everybody was a whole
[ __ ] town was over there probably had
200 people at that [ __ ]
and i pulled up and got out the van
and my damn step parents were right
there bro
damn dude and i couldn't even barely see
out of my eyes
i was just so just cooked out bro i mean
just like the devil had just been damn
grilling burgers up in my [ __ ] sight
balls baby i was just gassed up
and i don't know what i do i don't know
what i said to them
but
it wouldn't
it wasn't probably very good
but let's hear more brother onward
shout out uh
listen to the riffraff episode
just now heard you mentioned tiffany
lanes where he got that first little bit
of [ __ ] heat on you
yeah brother lost my virginity over
there behind tiffany lane's over there
on highway 190. beautiful little
establishment
if you like bowling or if you like
eating bad popcorn
and uh
seeing people be depressed about their
families and loved ones homeward
oh and the carpet was always wet in that
[ __ ] bro
dude i said every [ __ ] step was damp
up in there
just like the damn carpet just had that
you know
like it i i mean just like it had dang i
don't know what was in it
i think they didn't have any sub
flooring they might not have had any
flooring it might have been carpet
straight on damn swamp land bro
because there what i mean [ __ ]
that it was damp
tiffany lanes is now closed down
so
made me a little sad to hear that great
memory but i know exactly the place
you're talking about
and unfortunately with the pandemic that
closed it down so
anyway love the show
thank you brother thanks for that update
dang
you know things change and i i have
tough time dealing with that
i can't believe they closed it now we
need to go put a cross up or something
behind there
where i caught that
first 710 split baby where i picked up
that spare baby you know what i'm
talking about
getting cooter baby you heard me
but thank you brother thanks for sharing
that is
everything changes bro everything turns
into a [ __ ] lens crafters or
something you know
[ __ ] just hurts a little or a damn qs
diagnostics
dang it
what else i know we're kind of call
heavy here but uh
i want to hear what's going on with you
um
[Music]
what else can we get into
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry if this is call
heavy i'm not sorry about it um
but yeah it's just been a few weeks
since we've had a solo episode you know
and um
some of that's been because i'm just
so
you know
since i hadn't really been feeling like
myself you guys know that
and um
the hard part
sometimes with podcasting is putting
yourself out there when you don't feel
great
you know you want to put at least the
most
um
not the most comfortable you out there
but you want to at least be able to
you know get through the episodes
without feeling a lot of stress and
you know for a long time that was hard
for me i mean for two years it was tough
and i'm not i'm not crying about it
um
but i've been feeling better but i'm
just trying to you know
just trying to take it easy and um
and yeah
and i miss the solo episodes because i
miss i feel like this is where i get to
connect with people and hear what's
going on um
so maybe we're a little call heavy today
and uh
that's just how we're gonna be
um
[Music]
i'm excited i'm going down to austin
uh for the coming week
so i'm looking forward to that
uh what else is going on in my life my
sister we just got her into a new house
and um
you know that makes me
so happy
you know she has two little girls and
just to know that you know they'd had a
tree fell in their trailer and that
[ __ ] has been in there for eight months
and not not my sister that tree i mean
they're both [ __ ] but you know
they're but then they were both in there
uh
but uh just knowing that her and her
girls have a
roof over their head you know and a
washer dryer and just
you know
man
that makes me feel good
um
[Music]
my brother moved out to utah recently
and so i've been thinking a lot about
him and what his life is like and
you know
just what it's like to be in a new place
and
the challenges he probably feels and
stuff like that
um
[Music]
you know we had another family member we
tried an intervention on recently and uh
and that was just our choice
and
so i've been thinking a lot about them
and um
um
what else has been happening with me
uh
oh
um i'm gonna do a friend of mine asked
me to be in his movie so i'm gonna do
that next month it's about uh a sober
living
and it should be exciting
um
so it's not a huge time commitment and
it's like a new thing i didn't want to
do it
uh
but i'm trying to do contrary actions
and do things i don't want to do
because sometimes i get so set in my
comfort zone like oh i wa you know i'm
doing this i'm doing them
and and my life just going a certain way
and
and i want my life to be different but i
keep doing the same things
and so i'm like if i want to have
different feelings and stuff and
different experiences i have to do them
um
and sometimes i don't like doing new
stuff i don't
really want to try it i you know
sometimes that stuff scares me you know
i like to be
in control
i like to know the outcome of things i
like to you know somebody will invite me
to a movie and they'll take them they
want to see me like what's it what's it
going to be like i'll text stuff back
like that what's it what what the [ __ ]
is it gonna be like like a [ __ ] movie
you know
and i'm like who's who's gonna be there
and they're like who the [ __ ] is [ __ ]
dark
it's dark in there
and people's [ __ ] hiding and eating
damn jujubes dog
who gives a [ __ ]
you know but it's like i want to know
everything
i find that a lot for myself i've always
i want to know how everything's going to
go
so i can be okay
because if i know how everything's you
know there's not going to be any real
surprise then i can do you know
i'm in control it gives me some sense of
control
but what it takes away from me it takes
possibility
and you can't really have a lot of fun
if you don't have a lot of possibility
you know that's where fun happens
that's where something new happens it's
you know
and i think i used to be more relaxed
and more open about that but when my
life got real busy i got real scared
you know and and i just i was like i
just
i don't know i got real scared and i
didn't know how to con and the only
thing i knew how to do was i just i need
to
tighten down on control i got to control
everything
um
[Music]
anyway i don't even know what i was
talking about but
yeah that's just been what's been going
on with me so i've been trying to be
braver and try new things
um
and do things that could be different
and the funny thing is once i even
agreed to do my buddies project uh i
felt suddenly more excited
um
it started to turn and fear from fear
and like what's it gonna be like and
to like hopefulness like oh this could
be fun i'm going to get to meet some new
folks i'm going to get to be around some
fun people
bobby lee's going to be on there so i'm
going to get to be around him you know
it's like
things like that
um what else oh i've been writing a
movie script me and david spade wrote a
movie script together
so
[Music]
that's probably
a dream come true
even if it never even gets made man we
we worked hard
you know we worked hard
and my buddy adam e get on there helping
out and
and we worked really hard and this you
know
i don't know that's
so
uh
that's just stuff that's been going on
with me i guess i'm not trying to brag
but i'm i'm trying to share things that
are making me
uh feel excited and
um
yeah
that's what's going on let's get into
another call here
this was a video call too we get to see
this person this would be neat
theo what it do bro my name is kate i'm
from louisiana
i've always appreciated the homage that
you give to the place that you came from
the homage that you always give to
louisiana i think it's really important
that we remember where we come from so
we know where we're going that's
something that was instilled in me as a
young kid and i carry it to this day and
i'll hand it down to those who come
after me someday
um amen
yeah thank you for calling you sound
like you got a little bit of that ville
plaid in you baby
stuck in your throat there donna you got
a little bit of boo boo booyah bass in
you
you know you got that remoulade over
there in your windpipe baby you know
what i'm talking about you sound like
you from the lafayette area i'm guessing
boo onward and in that same vein
my question to you theo
is
do you feel a connection to your
ancestors and if you do
how does that connection show for you in
your life
how
how how do your ancestors manifest in
you theovonne in the year 2022.
um
well that's really uh that's that's
interesting um
you know
you know my father my father was a dang
ancestor i mean he was born in 1910 and
you know he passed away when i was 16
and
um
and my folks separated when i was seven
and so
sometimes
i still feel my father around so now
i'll feel my heartbeat
and sometimes i'll even put those
those
ear listeners on i got a stethoscope i
think it's called i don't know what it
is
from a doctor's office
and i'll listen to my heart and
uh
because it's really that's my father's
beat that's my grandfather's beat like
like a heartbeat is like
you know your parents made made that
it's from their heartbeats made your
heart beat
so it's really crazy that like
this sound of this heartbeat started
way back when and it's
it's still you know
it's in me this is this isn't my sound
it's my heart
but this was created
long this sound has kept going
it's been remixed by people doing sex
and making a new person
but this heartbeat this is
i mean this is my [ __ ] you know
this is the same [ __ ] beat that went
through my father
and my grandfather and
on up
i had a tough time with my own family
growing up and we were not very close
and
there wasn't a ton of education about
the grandparents and the family history
there wasn't a ton of it um
and i think that some of that
uh
you know i always wanted to be different
i i wanted to do my own thing
um
[Music]
so i think as i get over more of that
like resentment
i notice my own family connections
growing stronger these days
um
that uh i hope to have a
a greater
knowledge of
and not only a knowledge of but uh care
for
and i care to explore where i'm from
and what's inside of me what i'm made up
of
um
but yeah i think there's sometimes you
know sometime i'll see a little rabbit
go by or something and i'll feel a
little that native american kind of
tingling me
you know
um
yeah i mean i feel a connection to
louisiana i feel a connection to
covington where i'm from and that just
the you know i realize that
i love to tell the stories about my
youth and
and stories are important because that's
how we learn a lot of things
um
you know that's how you ins and instill
a lot of like uh the past into people
um
so yeah it's interesting i i don't i
feel a connection
but
i i would like to have more
you know i would like to have more
um
but for now i think i'm just working on
the gratitude
that i didn't get
here
alone
you know that i didn't do
or create me by myself
you know i think i've had resentments in
some of that space and so i gotta uh i'm
still working through some of that stuff
and
and that's okay
you know but i think that's an
interesting question
and i think it's important
you know i think it is really important
um because
if you tell your kid who is grandfather
and you introdu this is who he is and
this is what he did and this is who your
great-grandfather was and this your
great-grandmother and this is what she
did
you know that's because then they have a
history they have a meaning there's a
purpose
oh i'm a part of a chain i'm part of
something
you know
[Music]
i think that that stuff used to be huge
probably like in a lot of native uh
cultures and in other societies it might
be really big and in some other families
in our family it was not
there was not a lot of uh
sharing stories
of uh the past
you know um
and i think my father had some
i mean he grew up in a village you know
he said that there were
people eating dirt in his village that
people starved
um
but i
we were kind of ships passing in the
night
in our ages and our ability to connect
so
um
yeah i don't know that's a really
interesting question though
but i do think it's important because
then a kid doesn't feel like he's just
here
you know if he knows where he's from if
he knows his lineage if he knows who was
before him and what they believed and
what they were
um
i think that's really valuable stuff
uh i don't have a lot of that stuff in
me um but
i hope to gain more and i hope to if i
have a family of my own
uh
to have more information to pass on
you know i think i really hope that so
thank you for that call all right uh i
wanna um
yeah
i wanna thank you guys we got one more
call i'm gonna hit but uh i wanna just
wanna thank you guys just for uh
for tuning in
and for being a part of my life
and um and letting me be a part of your
life
you know um
that's cool
i think it's cool
and uh
and yeah i just want to let you know
that that uh yeah it means something to
me
and
you know one thing that i have that i
think about a lot is that this
this show and this group is important to
me
and um
yeah i just i
i don't know i want to be able to make
the most out of it and um
that's always a goal of mine
and that's something that even comes
back to me more uh the better i feel you
know it's like man if i'm feeling good
then i can really be a part of this
and uh
that's nice man so that's been a real
blessing
um let's check this one more we have one
more little uh deal he came in from a
young lady right here
so i can't help but die laughing every
time you bust out with uh i'm upstairs
i'm upstairs
you know that boo boo
i grew up in a two-story house and that
was a totally
valid excuse to not have to do something
you just yell i'm upstairs
so i started telling my seven-year-old
this we don't have any stairs in our
house but every time he wants me to do
something and i don't feel like doing it
for him i started yelling i'm upstairs
so now
this is what we do
hey jacoby
what
can you bring me my water bottle no i'm
upstairs
jacoby please bring me my water bottle
i'm upstairs
yeah baby
yeah you are jacoby dang huh
jacoby and you know booboo got with a
freaking
she got with her brother baby if you got
a jacobi running around that's beautiful
boo gang
i love it
i'm upstairs
best excuse in the book
no stairs basement only no problem i'm
upstairs
i love it thank you for that thank you
for that call and uh i hope jacoby's
doing well you give him a hug from us
and look
that's where i'm gonna try to stay i'm
going to try to stay upstairs man that's
all we're doing here we're just trying
to stay upstairs aren't we
i think that's it
you know things are going to get risky
you know things are just trying to stay
above it
you know or beside it or just you know
just try not to get stuck in the sludge
and try to take care of ourselves and
take care of one another too
i think that's good
um
but you guys be good to yourselves out
there huh
i know you can i know it's not easy
oh
but yeah take care of yourself it's
important
you know that we've created this society
that
there it feels like so much pressure
you know it feels like we don't even
exist sometimes anymore
um
[Music]
but i i don't know if i don't know if
that's real or if that's just
a side effect of something we've created
um
[Music]
i think the truth is
uh
that we are important
and that we do matter
and that
there is purpose
to us
i think we just got to refined our
footing a little
um
you know and i don't know exactly how we
do that
but i know that we can
and i know that we will
and in the meantime
just take it easy
you know
and be good to yourself
i know you can
and if you need me
i'll be upstairs
and if you're not up there then
come up
jacoby get my water bottle
i'm gonna come
[Music]
um
[Music]
well i just broke up with my baby
[Music]
well i just moved up to lucky street
when the mayor came and said to me
[Music]
well good things keep on coming
[Music]